my name is Leslie masterp and I'm
president of merrill lynch in South
Africa I think that one of the key
things to consider with respect to this
vision is that it's not going to be
government that will be the main driver
of the jobs that needs to be created in
decision a massive unemployment
specifically of young people I think we
have to begin to look at what are the
key enablers to get more people to look
at entrepreneurship as a potential
source of employment and economic
opportunity right now because a lot of
these countries are dependent on resort
exports dependent on oil is a commodity
people have been lulled into the idea
that you know the economy will always
grow and all revenues were always
increase as the whole price goes up
what's required now is for people to
make use of enablers like technology
specifically the education system I
think as a great role to play to for
people to develop the tools to become
successful entrepreneurs we also need to
celebrate successful entrepreneurs more
there are many people from this region
for example in the young global leader
community who have become very
successful but they are not put up there
as role models for the youth